i would like to invite our next speaker
dr rita sharma i would like to introduce
her
dr sharma is deeply inspired by the
historic innovations that led to the
domestication of modern day crop plants
and is equally astonished by the fact
that out of estimated 3 000 edible plant
species on the earth
we
human beings only cultivate about 150 of
them
with more than 70 percent of our
calories coming from only 15 crops
further more than 50 percent of these
calories are contributed by only three
cereal crops namely rice maize and meat
these choices driven by a simpler need
of feeding the increased population in
the past have to be revised in the wake
of limiting resources deteriorating
environment and changing nutritional
requirements
with an overall aim to gain deeper
insights into the evolution and
domestication of economically important
plants that led to modern day crops and
facilitate denomo domestication for the
development of multi-purpose climate
ready smart crops for the future her
research leverages the synergism of
plant biotechnology
and computational biology to facilitate
data driven precision agriculture
i'm very much excited to listen to dr
rita stock over to umack
thank you very much uh for a very nice
introduction um let me just share my
slides first um
okay
i believe my screen should be visible
now
yes ma'am it's visible it's in the
slideshow mode i think you're good to go
thank you mom okay
thank you thank you so much so um
although i've been introduced more like
a plant by a technologist using
computational biology but i have
prepared this presentation in a very
generalized mode because i understand
that the student
participants here may not be just
interested in the plant by technology
per se but would like to hear more about
the scenario of computational biology in
the country and how its impact is
increasing um over the time
so um
yeah so that's how i i titled my
presentation that how the boundaries
between biology and computational
biology is shrinking in terms of
education as well as research
so um first
yeah so just introducing first how my
academic journey started i have
started my journey it's a very pure
subject but bought me um from with
masters in botanical sciences from
gurdaan and university and then i moved
ahead to university of delhi south
campus for my phd program and followed
by postdoctoral research at university
of california davis and i returned back
to india in 2014 as a ramalinga swami
fellow in jahalala near university
school of life sciences and in between i
also went back to uc berkeley and
lawrence berkeley national laboratories
in united states for a visiting
scientist fellowship program and
throughout this journey which was which
i call as a formal training that helped
me establish my own research group i was
challenged with high therapy data which
was generated from high therapy
technologies so may it be the first
experiment i was supposed to do in my
phd was microarrays and then sage
experiments involving sequencing of
thousands
of bases and then followed by uh
computational um comparative genomic
studies where i we could make sense of
the data that we had got using high
therapy technologies and during my
postdoc also i was involved in
switchgrass and fox eliminated genome
sequencing projects and then
we thought of making databases to make
it available to the public community and
make resources for others also to use so
this is how i transitioned from a
botanist to a molecular biologist to our
computational biologist
and
considering that exposure that i had
over the time i was appointed as
assistant professor at the udc recharge
program in johannes university in the
school of computational and integrative
sciences we call it as computational
integrative sciences because it's a very
very unique department in the sense that
it has faculty who are coming from very
different disciplines there are physics
there are chemists they're biologists
and they all integrate
their domain expertise with the
computational sciences to make sense of
the big data that we were generating in
our groups and in terms of education in
jnu this department hosts a postgraduate
diploma in big data analytics which was
just started a few years ago and then we
had an mtech program from 2006 to 2015
which was discontinued and then later we
started masters program
msc in computational biology as well as
phd where we have computational biology
and complex systems so um this these
programs were some of the programs which
were this sort of you know made the
inception of the computational biology
in the country and
we continuously revise those curriculum
to make
room for the growing needs and um right
now i'm at with filani i joined here
last year and in here we have a very
single interdisciplinary sort of
department called biological sciences
with 20 faculty members all we diverse
expertise and the boundary between
bioinformatics computational biology and
biology has totally blurred because all
of us use computational
sciences as a tool sort of to complement
the science that we do and that's how we
identify ourselves some of us who
actually use computer science
tools as computational biologists not a
bioinformaticians because uh you know if
we start thinking about differentiating
between the two you would see very
definitions available on different
sources on internet and it is not
possible for every one of us to agree
with one particular definition but the
one which was given by russ ultimate at
stanford university in a blog that he
wrote
impressed me the most and which connects
with where i feel connected is that
computational biology is the study of
the biology where you are using
computational techniques so you are
essentially a biologist who is using
computational techniques to assist the
research so it is more about exploratory
science discovery science and we are
using computers as just one of the tools
just like we do experiments whereas
bioinformatics is more towards creation
of the tools where their tools are
created to help the biological problems
so they are created for the
computational biology so for example
there could be certain tools which are
available which are designed by a
bioinformatician but i may be the user
of those to solve my own particular
research problem so i would call that
person maybe as a bioinformatician
myself as a computational biologist
although these again definitions are
blurring with the people having coming
with the interdisciplinary knowledge of
the domain so anyone who has a domain
knowledge of biology statistics
mathematics
and computer science can do i either
into bioinformatics and computational
biologists or even both you don't have
to be one of them but how
bioinformaticians were perceived uh you
know decades ago was more of people who
would technically help computational
biologists or general biologists to
achieve their research goals so they
they used to work like mostly as
technical posts where they would develop
tools for the biologists and but that
changed as we entered into the era of
sequencing and you know high therapy
technologies so even if you see the
human genome sequencing project and most
of you might already know eric lander
who was the lead scientist who led the
human genome sequencing project from mit
and howard and he was basically a
mathematician and a molecular biologist
he he did not have any degree in
computer science and he was the one who
led the human genome sequencing project
but he had some very good scientists who
identified themselves as
bioinformatician to provide the support
for assembly and making sense of the
data which was being generated by the
sequencer so and those people change the
scenario how we look at
bioinformaticians versus computational
biologists because they started joining
heads together to lead the projects
together instead of one working for the
other person so this is just to show you
some of the lead bioinformaticians who
have
gone up to the extent of leading
some very huge international projects as
far as indian context is concerned in
india more systematic investigation of
bioinformatics and education started
with the inception of the btis network
which was established by department of
biotechnology in 1980s before that there
were some people who were doing by
self-learning mode some of the
bioinformatics things but there was not
a formal training
available for bioinformatics so in 1986
with the establishment of btis network
there were
gics which were established so basically
in btis network this is still existing
and very much functional and is the
source of
connecting bioinformatics in the country
where we have several distributed
information centers bioinformatics
facility centers which have high
performance and super computing
facilities available there are seven
centers of excellence which are running
the programs in masters and pge programs
for bioinformatics there are distributed
information sub centers which also
include northeastern state facility
centers which together make uh you know
a very strong foundation for the
bioinformatics in the country so there
are seven centers of excellence there
are 11 dics 51 sub gics and 98
bioinformatics infrastructure facilities
so you can imagine that we are really
quite well resourced to lead
bioinformatics project and some of the
universities which were the ones who
actually took the initiative the first
ones to start the bioinformatics in the
country where pune university
university and still those programs are
very well designed
to meet the needs and they're all
uniformly distributed across the country
so that the students would have access
to these centers
wherever they are located but there has
been in spite of all these
bioinformatics resources training
centers we still had the gap that
students after completing these programs
are not getting jobs in the industry so
what was that gap that has to be
fulfilled between the academic
curriculum and the industrial
requirements so there has been uh you
know the people who were leading the
committees in the bioinformatics boards
and bdis centers they they thought about
it that what is uh no missing that is
not letting our students get the no good
jobs in industry and after a lot of
thought and all for last couple of years
now dbt has come up with association
with lssdc some skill development
programs as you know earlier speaker was
also mentioning where they have a six
month certification program where the
six month or one year certification
programs have been started in several uh
you know national repute institutes
where students are
they go through the curriculum which is
designed in consultation with the
industry so the industry needs are met
and these certificate courses and all
can be finished after your completion of
the formal degree and that can help you
to have more formal uh you know
education as per the industry
requirements so usually they have some
component which is theoretical uh you
know courses which are done uh as per
the standard curriculum followed by some
visitation or outdoor project which
preferably has to be done in industry so
that you get a real exposure to the you
know industry problems and then
eventually you can apply that so this
this is one step that you know dbt has
taken to help students bridge that gap
and you know get jobs in industry
and uh professor alook bhattacharya who
was
earlier at school of life sciences jnu
um he's retired now but now still very
active man he is the one who is chairing
this ptis network and has made
significant contribution in comparative
genomic studies with you know especially
with microbial genomes mycobacteria and
so on and then um i also put the picture
of my phd supervisor professor akhilesh
tyagi from
university of delhi south campus who was
among the first people who took
initiative
for getting involved into international
projects involving genome sequencing so
that was where the challenge started to
come that we needed to have teams who
can come together to meet those deadline
oriented projects so professor tagi was
involved in first rice genome sequencing
that he took up into tomato genome
sequencing and then dc chickpea when he
was director of nipgr so these are the
people who actually took the those were
not computer scientists by training they
were actually life scientists they were
biologists who took the initiative made
the teams construct the teams and led
those projects which were heavily
computational biology oriented
and uh but you know in these are few
people who had taken that stance not
everybody can lead the projects at that
level so still there were people who
were calling themselves as
bioinformaticians and would still just
like to call themselves as biologists
and then how to bring them together and
initiate collaboration so there has been
several initiatives to do that also and
now dbt has started the more of uh
national network projects where the
people who are actually not by
bioinformaticians or computational
biologists but would like to take help
of bioinformatician computational
biologists for integrated national level
projects they are now calls for
proposals where they can together
propose you know bigger network projects
to help them collaborate with each other
and some of the very beautiful examples
in our country where this network
projects have been you know very
successful is the national mango
database where a lot of institutes came
together to develop a mango database
being one of the most important fruit
crop in our country then we have indie
genomes project which is completed by uh
led by the researchers that igib and
ecsar with other i think 16 or 17
different institutes together to
sequence more than thousand indian human
genomes so that you could have a
representation of the indian
genomes as well and they have
constructed a database to make it freely
available for others to do and extend
this research
there is also been uh uh initiative by
national mission on education through
ict where they have come up with the
viduan portal where researchers can
actually uh register themselves with
their expertise and then using that
expertise these databases are searchable
so if you search bioinformatician or by
computational biologists you will know
how many bioinformatics people are
working in the country so that you if
you want looking for a collaboration you
would get them domain wise as well as
geographically wise where they are
located how many of them are in central
universities state universities private
universities so that you can find the
right fit for collaboration you don't
have to just depend on your local
network you can go to this database and
you can find out closest to you what who
are the bioinformaticians computational
biologists who might be accessible and
you would like to connect with them to
initiate collaboration so i just did a
quick search before this talk and there
are about more than 400
bioinformaticians and more than 1600
computational biologists who are
registered in this portal and hopefully
available for collaborative initiatives
there are student groups also who are
taking initiatives to connect with each
other um international society of
computational biology has a regional
student group format where the students
can come together to make a regional
group of any country so there is rsg
india there is others the u.s australia
sri lanka and so on so these student
groups they come together and then they
network and they organize events so we
have an artistry india team who is very
active i'm faculty advisor for them
and they have been doing certain events
to bring together students and invite
experts based on the needs of the
students whom they feel they would like
to listen to and
you know you can also network amongst
each other to you know talk about what
kind of research you are doing with each
other so i encourage the students to go
and check the rst india website and the
events which they are organizing
also we don't have to just network in
between the country we also have to work
with international levels so there are
challenges why india is no
it is now expanding and growing so we
have to have uh know our place at the
international forum also in
computational biology and bioinformatics
and for that also there are several
initiatives which have been started and
one of them is where i was also one of
the pis when i was at jnu is the
research training group which is mostly
focused on big data research that is an
initiative between dbt and heidelberg
germany
for a combined graduate degree so the
idea is that the students in the
participating institutes from india will
go to germany for a few months get a
training there and then they would have
a joint degree by the the host institute
as well as the
the heidelberg
host partner so so there are institutes
like jnuit madras iit kanpur iit kohati
who are participating in this and some
of the students have already completed
their training in heidelberg for the
making this program a
reality so these are some very wonderful
programs that students they are aware
can take advantage of also in terms of
computing infrastructure you might have
heard about the first supercomputers
being installed in iit delhi but now we
have several institutes of eminence
universities where the super computers
have been installed and are in the
process so that the the dream of having
a national super computing mission can
be accomplished over the years in the
future so that that won't be a limit for
us to think of ambitious projects also
there are people uh you know who are
taking initiatives to bring the science
in india on international following one
of those examples is apb and society
it's asia pacific bioinformatics
interaction and networking society which
is registered in delhi and uh
some of the faculty at jnu and
um calcutta boston university and assam
university and so on are the founding
members who came together they're all
bioinformatician computational
biologists i'm also one of them we and
then com made this society where we can
organize international conferences the
first international conference is
organized in 2018
info and hopefully there will be more
which will place you know the indian
bioinformaticians and computational
biologists on the international forum
where we can talk to each other discuss
our science and then initiate
international collaborations
and um now uh
as i said i identify myself as a
computational biologist but the
computational biologist doesn't mean
that you know it's a different stream
slowly the the gap between computational
biology and biology is also minimizing a
lot of students when they come they say
i'm not good at computers so i just want
to do better experiments but i tell them
that that's not going to sustain you
because slowly in biology also we are
moving from single gene to genome level
from single rna to transcriptomes from
single protein to proteomes from one
metabolite to metabolism so science is
transforming very very fast and the way
the technology is becoming so cheap it
is so cheap to study at genome level why
would you look at just one gene when you
can actually look at the whole genome so
and then because of this the integration
of all these would require quantitative
skills mathematical skills and
computation skills so if you want to
really survive in biology you will see
that slowly these two are actually
merging together to make one stream all
computational biology and biology is
going to be the same if if you are doing
biology you can't say that i cannot use
computers because computers have now
just become one tool in the arsenal of
the biologists not a separate science
anymore and at best pilani
we have students who are doing b-tech in
mechanical engineering in chemical
engineering computer science and so on
and they come to us and then they talk
to our biological projects and they
apply their knowledge whether it is
engineering computer science and they do
short-term projects where they
combine those disciplines together to
come up with the innovative solutions
and that is how you know i think where
bits leads and innovates because it is
combining together it is not looking at
these streams as separate streams the
students from any stream can go to
faculty of any stream and then do the
projects with them and that is the
beauty of interdisciplinary nature of
science where you can combine the
knowledge together
now there's just the last one thing i
would like to uh share about that you
know as i said a lot of us are
generating a lot of data in my lab also
i generate a lot of transcriptomic state
and i had handled proteomics
metabolomics projects over the time
but you know what happens is that lot of
labs who generate this data either they
will submit it to some international
repositories if that too is mandatory by
the journal so when you are publishing a
paper some journals mandate that you
have to submit to a national repository
and in those cases you are bound to
submit but if it is not required you may
not submit and if it is not published
then obviously most of the people want
submit and make it publicly available so
that makes a huge gap that you know the
the indian funding agencies are funding
these huge projects and then the data
stays in one lab stuck in one computer
and then it is never accessible to
others and so it is important for us to
be able to access at least the data
which is generated from indian cultures
indian varieties indian strains indian
populations
and so with that vision in mind gpt has
initiated an indian biological data
center which is uh being hosted um at
rcb faridabad and it is uh having
clusters together at meshware nic and
rcb and dr saudi ragwenshi who also
played a very instrumental role in rice
genome sequencing project with professor
akhilesh jagi at delhi university is
leading this initiative where they are
trying to make an indian database for
all the different type of biological
data that we generate in india using the
public funding and so that that would be
accessible by indian researchers and the
idea is that you know whether the data
is coming from agriculture livestock
microbes humans doesn't matter anything
which is being generated in india should
be put into one database and that it
should be searchable and it should be
available to the community for use and
expand and build on that research right
now they are the running the pilot
project and they are working on mostly
nucleotide database but they have a plan
to work on different domains where no
domain specifically there will be
different domains for different types of
data in this database and that would be
accessible to the community as far as my
lab is concerned
as i have already been introduced i am a
plant biotechnologist and i am mostly
interested in crop improvement and for
that we usually select start with
selection of some of the lines some of
the seeds that we want to start with and
ultimately we want to make an improved
crop out of it right but then the the
work that goes in between from selecting
the geoplasm to having an improved crop
is tremendous because you have you know
when you talk about a genome you have
thousands of genes and you don't know
which one should be you know edited to
get an improved crop and you cannot
edit those thousands of genes because
as far as editing and transformation in
plants is concerned we are very very
limited in terms of technology it takes
about six months to one year to be able
to have some validated transgenic lines
for single gene so this is not even
possible for us to even think of
characterizing thousands of genes and
this is where computational biology has
always come very handy in my own
research where we use high therapeutic
technologies to generate data at genome
scale and then use uh you know other
tools like phylogenomics combined with
the pathway mapping and all to shortlist
the candidates which are you know can
then be again bought into the lab for
precise editing either using genome
editing tools or the other conventional
tools to improve the crop plants so this
is how uh you know my research is being
also benefited as a computation with the
computational biology and by just
accepting that you know ex computational
biology is not a different science it is
it is one of my tools and if i want to
make progress i have to learn you know i
think anyone can you know make change
and that takes your research at a very
different level
so uh with that take home lesson i think
i'll just stop here
and let
the host uh
take over and if there are any questions
i'll be happy to answer
thank you so much ma'am
so are there any questions you can
please put them in the chat box
and also thank you so much mom the way
you beautifully explained how
computational biology and biology are
merged together
has helped me a lot uh to make this
community understand as well because as
a community manager i keep on getting
questions from biotechnologies students
who say
how to get started with computational
biology or why shall we do it or how to
do it they're scared maybe
and
they keep on asking such questions
because they are just confused so your
talk has definitely given such students
a direction that competition the
knowledge of computational tools is
definitely very important to accept
uh in these times
so thank you so much thank you very much
and also the information that you gave
about these groups it was very much
helpful
okay so i have a question what is the
skill that is most needed in
bioinformatics for a student what do you
think
i can't pinpoint one because that
depends as i said on your research
question right so i i know students who
don't even know programming but they are
still able to handle data with the
publicly available platforms like galaxy
where you don't have to really write the
programs so and there are certain uh
areas where you have to write a program
because there is nothing available so it
it totally depends on the kind of
research area you are working on and
what resources are available for that
particular system if you are working on
a model system you probably would have
lot of information and you may not have
to go back
and people would have already developed
programs and algorithms to help you and
databases which might be available but
if you're working in a challenging new
system then you have to again start from
scratch so i think it totally depends on
what you are working on
but but what i would say is that i don't
think there is anything you know that
can limit
starting from scratch just makes you
know confident enough that you can do it
again if required right
yes i completely agree with you uh the
next question is
is there a demand for computational
biologists in agriculture in india
of course there is a lot of demand see
um
when you look at the demand you you
would see that you know a lot of
opportunities they come in the projects
which are mostly related to human
genomes and microbial genomes because of
the amount of funding which goes in the
medical sciences health informatics the
data which is generated in
animal sciences is usually much higher
folds compared to plant sciences because
the amount of funding that goes in plant
sciences is not equivalent to what goes
in health research so usually when we
talk about big data the big data usually
comes from the human resources so that's
why you see most of the employment
opportunities staggered towards those
projects which are focused if you are
talking about last two years lot of
funding has gone into you know kovid
related research which makes sense and
is sensible approach but in case of
plants although we are not generating
the scale the data at the scale where
human and microbial genomes
are being sequenced and data is getting
accumulated but that does not mean that
you know there is not enough requirement
because although
we are not sequencing thousands of
genomes but then people in agricultural
sciences because of the lack of funding
are very very selective and the kind of
polymorphism the kind of variation which
is present in the plant genomes is much
more daunting uh assembling a human
genome would i guess would be easier
than assembling a complex polyploid
plant genome
it takes years i worked with stretch
ground genome sequencing and it took us
10 years from beginning to it was it is
a you know aloe polyploid which means it
has two genomes and it's a huge you know
and just coming up with the complete
assembly was more than 10-year project
so
there are a lot of daunting and
challenging projects which are available
in agriculture as well and as we are
heading towards you know understanding
the requirements in agricultural
sciences these projects are going to
increase over the time especially with
the directive that has come yesterday
from indian government we are now crispr
edited crops are not going to be
assessed for safety requirements lot of
people would now you know try to put
their food into this area to be able to
generate improved crops and again as i
said for generating improved crops you
have to take science help of
computational biology so of course as i
said the demand is there and it is
increasing over the time and we would
love to have some very good you know
bioinformatics students coming and
joining our group and contributing in
the research
thank you mom
and the next question is
what would be an acceptable level of
education required for one to get a job
in bioinformatics what do you think
in bioinformatics when you talk about
job there are jobs at different levels
so that also depends whether you are
looking for a job in industry or
academia whether you want to uh
go into a technical team and you want to
join as a research analyst you want to
join as a data scientist
minimum requirements would actually
again depend on the job the kind of job
um and the you know growth opportunities
available in that particular area so i
don't think there's a single answer to
that question as well i'm sorry
you're right ma'am and habiba is asking
does one need to know how to code to use
bioinformatics tools and which is the
best language r python
[Music]
r and python i think both are
really important for any student to you
know excel in bioinformatics because i
don't think they are as complicated as c
plus plus and all java and all if if you
are the starter a beginner
there are certain things where r is more
helpful compared to python and there are
certain things where python so i would
suggest you to do both at least r and
python um and they're not very difficult
languages and you know once you
understand them
probably there is nothing much that you
cannot do
without having to know other languages
so but yes these two i think are equally
important
right ma'am uh just one last question
um
is there a repository for accessing
agricultural army data from india
uh the indian databases uh so far as i
said are either individual centric like
for example the mango database which is
only for mango and then we have this
rice irgsp database genome india
initiative which is for accessing the
rice database and similarly for
chickpeas so depending upon the crop
plant either there are individual crop
databases but there is no one single
repository for all the plant genomes
especially for indian the varieties
which have been sequenced in india and
this indian biological database
initiative dbt is the one which is going
to fill this gap in coming years
otherwise if you look at the global way
then phytosome is one repository where
you would find the plant genome
sequences which have been initiated by
the
joint genome institute in usa by far as
far as i know that is the biggest
repository for accessing the plant
genome data
specifically but that does not go only
with the
plant indian varieties that's the
varieties which have been chosen to
sequence but those are not just limited
to varieties which are in united states
there are some indian varieties also
which are there in the pool and they
also have pan genomes for certain crop
species so i think for now that will be
a useful repository for you if you are
working on plants but over the time
hopefully the ipgc will also have this
information from the genomes which are
being sequenced in india
that's quite interesting
thank you so much ma'am